aquí tenemos un cuadrilátero arbitrario
que está inscrito en este círculo y lo
que quiero demostrar es que sin importar
cuál sea realmente este cuadrilátero
inscrito los ángulos opuestos siempre
digamos van a ser suplementarios es
decir que la suma de las medidas por
ejemplo de este ángulo con la de este
ángulo que son opuestos la suma de sus
medidas nos debe dar siempre 180 grados
y la forma en la que voy a demostrarlo
es suponiendo que la medida de este
ángulo por ejemplo que la medida de este
ángulo que tenemos aquí es de x grados
muy bien ahora lo que tendríamos que
hacer es demostrar que la medida del
ángulo opuesto este que tenemos aquí es
de 180 grados
- x grados verdad así por ejemplo si
vale 180 menos x y le sumamos x entonces
nos da 180 grados la suma de las medidas
de estos ángulos verdad así que como
siempre te invito a que hagas una pausa
trates de demostrar por tu propia cuenta
que es
mide 180 menos x y te voy a dar una
sugerencia esto este problema tiene que
relacionarse con la medida de los arcos
que estos ángulos definen
muy bien vamos a hacerlo todos juntos
vamos a empezar viendo cuál es el arco
que está definido por este ángulo verdad
y me estoy refiriendo justamente a este
arco que estoy intentando remarcar con
amarillo o al menos es un buen intento
verdad aquí está este arco en color
amarillo verdad y ya hemos visto en
otros vídeos la relación que existe
entre un ángulo inscrito y la medida del
arco que define ese ángulo verdad y la
relación que existe es que este ángulo
será igual a la mitad de la medida del
arco que define verdad entonces si éste
es la mitad de la medida de este arco es
decir x es la mitad de la medida del
arco amarillo quiere decir que la medida
del arco amarillo es 2x verdad esto está
dado en grados muy bien ahora fijémonos
qué pasa con el arco digamos que está
definido desde este vértice hasta este
otro pero
que digamos es conjugado al otro arco
verdad es decir estamos pensando en este
que completa la vuelta verdad que
completa todo el círculo y justamente
como completa todo el círculo verdad la
suma de las medidas tiene que ser 360
grados entonces cómo podríamos calcular
la medida de éste de este arco azul pues
sería 360 grados y restarle la medida
del arco amarillo que es 2x verdad así
que la medida de este arco azul será 360
menos 2x y todo esto estará dado en
grados verdad entonces ahora nos
preguntamos cuál es el ángulo que
sostiene a este arco azul verdad
entonces si nos fijamos bien el arco que
perdona el ángulo que sostiene al arco
azul es justamente éste el cual queremos
calcular su medida verdad entonces qué
es lo que vamos a hacer bueno otra vez
hay que utilizar la relación de que la
medida del ángulo inscrito es igual a la
mitad
de la medida del arco que sostiene
verdad entonces esto sería la mitad de
360 menos dos menos dos equis verdad
entonces esto como lo calculamos bueno
la mitad de 360 serían 180 verdad esto
sería igual a 180 y la mitad de menos 2x
sería menos x verdad entonces justamente
este ángulo que tenemos aquí tiene una
medida de 180 menos x grados verdad
entonces con esto hemos demostrado que
estos dos ángulos son suplementarios
porque si sumamos 180 menos x y sumamos
x entonces nos da 180 grados entonces
estos dos ángulos opuestos son
suplementarios